la inauguración de la co27 se hizo
esperar una hora y media pero lo hizo
con buenas noticias la inclusión en la
agenda oficial de la discusión de las
llamadas perdidas y daños es decir cómo
pagar por los costos derivados de los
impactos que no se pueden evitar o que
ya han sucedido como consecuencia del
calentamiento global unos impactos que
sufren en su mayoría los países en
desarrollo que son los que menos han
contribuido al cambio climático el tema
que ha venido reclamando desde hace más
de 30 años los países menos
industrializados fue de hecho lo que
alargó las negociaciones previas a la
sesión inaugural y que causó el retraso
de la conferencia en sus discursos tanto
el presidente de la cop 26 y el
británico al oxharma como el que recibió
el testigo de las negociaciones de la
con 27 el egipcio
same sucre pidieron que el contexto
político y económico actual no desvíe la
atención de la crisis climática por su
parte el jefe de cambio climático de la
ONU recordó que mientras la guerra en
Ucrania y la inflación derivada ellas
son temporales el cambio climático está
empeorando aunque dice que sabemos cómo
frenarlo Y tenemos las herramientas
ahora solo falta implementarlas
precisamente la implementación es lo que
busca el presidente de la con 27 en la
Cumbre de líderes que inicia mañana
lunes con más de 120 jefes de gobierno y
de estado Eso sí con grandes ausencias
como las de China Rusia o India el
presidente de Estados Unidos giova y no
asistirá mañana ni el martes pero sí
vendrá a la co-27 el 11 de noviembre una
vez haya pasado las elecciones de medio
término en su país